ah that is creepy this is the weirdest
thing I've ever held in there right the
baby Jack sequence might be my favorite
sequence of the whole movie Jack Black
gets turned into the jack black baby
his body turns to a baby and the head is
life-sized and I don't know where it
came from
I just had an image of it I thought it'd
be really funny it's me but it's uh it's
like another character genuinely is
scary we molded Jack's face we sculpted
it it's disturbing you look at this
thing and it's legitimately creepy
Adrian Moreau is genius and I do not use
that word lightly he designed the most
beautiful animatronic Jack Black baby
it's amazing it looks real it looks just
like him every time I look Emily does
not jack then if I when I cover the body
I'm like what what everyone on set is
really creeped out by the baby it was
creepy that's a good sign when people
are walking by that thing or uh get that
thing away from me I'm like all right
that's the sweet spot we wanted me
[Music]